alors on comprend que la mairesse
globalement est contente de ce qu'elle a
vu dans la nouvelle mouture de ce gros
projet de transport en commun de 10
milliards de dollars le train de l'ès 1
attention luc ferrandez bonsoir bonsoir
bonsoir je vais vous montrer la carte là
pour le montrer beaucoup avec eux charbo
tout à l'heure mais c'est c'est un gros
projet ça ça va de l'extrémité de l'île
pointe aux trembles et ça va jusqu'au
centre-ville il ya un petit bout on voit
la carte ça vous paraît petit mais
c'est la ligne font celles qui parlent
de l'extrême s et qui se rend jusqu'au
centre-ville centre-ville on va voir le
vidéo que la caisse a dévoilé
aujourd'hui
avec des caténaires plus petits avec d
un parc linéaire en dessous avec des
gens qui rient en dessous de les fleurs
c'est très joli le caniche commence avec
vous vous avez milité pour ça vous
connaissez l'est de montréal
est ce que ce nouveau sa nouvelle
bouture vous satisfait ben je vois que
les commentaires ont été pris au sérieux
dans le comité en trop je vois que
beaucoup d'avancement mais aussi
beaucoup de modifications qui ont été
mis en place entre les côtes et les
caténaires on en parlait combien avec
fils je me souviens des dépôts des
positions de l'udc le tueur qui c'est
vrai que c'est surprenant aujourd'hui on
ne sommes maintenant à l'écran c'est
quand même plus petits c'est quand même
plus soft ça faisait ça s'intègre mieux
dans le dans le projet mais il faut se
rappeler avant tout c'est pô juste un
projet de transport c'est un projet de
développement de l'est de montréal c'est
un toulon change vraiment et lorsqu'on
parle de combien de personnes vont le
prendre il faut calculer convoi
développé il ya presque dans le projet
70000 possible 70000 logements de
possible de construire autour du dur m
mais il ya aussi le développement de
l'est de montréal je reviendrai pas sur
la dernière discussion qu'on a eue là
dessus mais encore plusieurs millions
pire harry a développé donc il vaut
rejet d'ensemble mais chaleur sur la
partie centre-ville que l'on
voilà les pilons plus petits les
structures à la structure arrondie
c'est moins massif que le premier règles
alors le qu'est ce que çà çà çà grâce à
vos yeux
oui il faut dire que je suis bien
content de voir ça et même un peu fier
de constater que à montréal of steel
enfin faire des choses à dire que c'est
un projet qui passait pas le
l'interprétation artistique de designers
et d'architectes et ça c'est formidable
il faut pas cracher dans la soupe tout
le temps je suis bien content de voir ça
la trémie cette idée l'aude de faire une
sortie extérieure
sur laquelle on va faire une place
publique c'est aussi intéressant mais
plusieurs éléments mentionnés d'abord
vous remarquerez que les vues sur cette
place publique sont tout le temps prises
par un drone c'est à dire que au niveau
du trottoir au niveau du trottoir quand
on va marcher puis qu'on va faire face à
cette entrée durée 1 me sous terre on va
être bloquée par un mur mur qui va faire
une vingtaine de mètres et parce que ça
va c'est lorsqu'un peintre ayant une
image très loin non ça c'est la station
mais c'est vrai il va ramer nous avoir
vus quand on est au niveau du sol devant
un mur c'est quand on est sur
l'équipement que là on va avoir une
belle vue de montréal c'est ça qu'on
voit là c'est exactement ce qu'on voit
une femme qui joue là c'est alors vous
avez remarqué de l'aca ça monte ça monte
ça monte on ne peut pas passer de voir
comment le
ceba lewis et on le voit a juste à
droite
c'est bon qu'ils mettent plus qu'à se
mettent plus bas c'est là que sont les
piétons
oui à la première chose deuxième chose
rappelez vous de sur coup sûr qu il y
avait un magnifique projet avec une
dalle parc j'avais même mis un trait ans
une dalle pas compris mètres de là des
armes des arbres centenaires qui courent
c'est comme ça dans les airs et ça ne
s'est jamais fait ça ne s'est jamais
fait on a fait sur courbe on n'a jamais
fait la dalle pas parce que ça coûtait
270 millions quand on a commencé à
calculer ça peut te 270 millions et
celle éléments du projet qui a été
abandonnée alors quels éléments du
projet de ce projet devait être
abandonné si ce que madame plan dit
madame claude moi je le trouve super
votre projet mais j'ai pas d'argent pour
le pays c'est ça ce public de cette
taille là c'est très très très cher et
en plus une place publique sur elvis est
encore plus cher la presse la place des
montréalaises par exemple votre contrat
côté de la place d'armes ça donne une
idée on parle de près de 200 millions là
donc ça c'est très apporté à ce que vous
êtes un luxe c'est que annie je vous
passe à paroles là tu sais que le madame
cohen a dit entre autres dans son
rapport à 10,1 va avec l'autre on peut
pas juste mettre la structure est pas
enjoliver et pistes cyclables la place
qui monte et elle c'est une place qui se
déroule d'ailleurs tout au long de cette
portion de rené lévesque ça la quête
mais charvaux viens de le dire aussi il
paye pas pour seule une paye pour le le
train alors faut que la ville ait trouvé
du financement pour ce soir à nîmes mais
pour moi ça fait partie d'un ensemble
c'est sûr que c'est pô juste à la casse
à payer pour tout ça c'est quand même un
changement pour la ville on change
vraiment la façon de faire or modifie le
boulevard rené lévesque or ajoute des
pistes cyclables et le moi je vois le
bel une belle occasion de faire un rêve
jusque dans pointe-aux-trembles
directement jusqu'à montréal le chemin
est fait tout est là donc en dessous on
fait le rêve on est capable enfin sur
les rues saint denis on est capable en
faire un peu partout mais je pense que
si on devrait la ville devrait profiter
dans ses programmes de péter de faire un
rêve directement l'appui de leur entrée
en même temps que c'est en train de se
faire on le fera pas de dix ans plus
tard mais qu'on le fasse maintenant
pendant que les travaux vont se faire
qu'on en profite pour le chantier de
face et bien place là puis ça va
permettre aux gens de co2 crime il faut
de l'argent alors je sais pas on n'est
jamais l'art de l'argent on en a de
l'argent confère un réel sur saint denis
comme ça en humiliant on en fait
d'autres comme ceux ya pas de problème
on parle d'un projet de 10 milliards de
dollars la ville et le gouvernement du
québec vont être capables mais des sous
la dent mais c'est aussi le rôle de la
russe la ville veut prendre les
décisions faudrait aussi qu'après les
décisions avec l'argent qui vient avec
je reviens sur l'autre oui j'en viens
sur l'autre argument qui a été avancé
chez certains disent à savoir
cannibaliser la ligne verte on peut voir
sur la carte les ja il devait avoir à
henri bourassa une jonction il y en aura
plus parce que le train passe on le voit
plus au sud donc là la partie verte là
il n'y a pas de station ski en bleu pâle
n'existe plus bref
est ce que vous achetez ça vous êtes
vous d'accord avec cette critique là le
cas ni le tout d'abord que ça va enlever
du budget à la stm des clients restés m
mais le rapport de la rtm signale que il
y aurait 12 % de nouveaux clients et 80
la différence donc 88 % de clients qui
sont déjà dans le transport en commun et
donc que oui il va y avoir une tête qui
sera pas aussi grande que ça parce que
madame rouleau a dit on oublie qu'il va
y avoir beaucoup de constructions qui
vont être faites au fil du temps le long
dur et aiment et ce sont des nouveaux
clients qui vont s'ajouter ça va prendre
des décennies pour ce soit significatif
au départ ce sont des gens qui utilisent
le transport en commun selon les
chiffres de la rtm est alors oui ils ont
connu en koni balises
charbon répond à ses yeux qu'est annie
très bien mais là si on veut un
transport en 30 minutes en pointe aux
trembles et le centre-ville on ne peut
pas demander aux gens de faire 36 mode
de transport non plus à venir elles ont
l'impression coeur on trouve toujours
quelque chose qui fonctionne pole mais
c'était le but de l'exercice la raison
pour laquelle ils ont changé leur trajet
justement parce que le comité d'experts
avait fait des commentaires c'était trop
proche des résidences veulent changer le
trajet ils changent le trajet on se rend
compte que oui c'est un projet mais
c'est un projet à long terme menacée par
un projet de demain matin ça va être
plein mais la ligne verte est déjà plein
la ligne orange est déjà plein puis on
le sait moi j je le prends la ligne
orange s'est toujours plaint mais le
tenant on va offrir un service oui il va
avoir du développement qui voit sens
dans les prochaines années dans
pointe-aux-trembles on parle peut-être
des cinquante mille logements plus il ya
quand même ça il faut qu'on y pense pour
pas arriver dans dix ans pitt et on
avait oublié créé pour avoir plus de
membres il faut il faut qu'on prenne
tout ça en compte d'un projet immense
d'un projet pour les 50 prochaines
années en tout cas encore en effet le
métro dernière question est ce que vous
suggérez oui lequel rapidement donc ça
fait souvent monsieur roy que vous
revenez sur cette question là de dire
mais là on a un projet il est structuré
il a ses qualités il va chercher les
gens à des dizaines de kilomètres qu'on
va pas cracher dessus quand même sur ce
goût là vous avez raison c'est n'est pas
juste c'est un élément mais c'est moi je
voudrais pas paraître pour avoir raison
c'est un élément à mettre dans la
balance il faut le mettre dans la
balance il faut regarder si les autres
arguments qui sont dans la balance aussi
le coût du projet sur 100 ans l'impact
qui va y avoir la fréquentation va aux
maîtres l'autre côté de la balance de
quel côté penche la balance
je vous forçait à dire oui ou non est ce
que vous signez est-ce qu'on donne le
feu vert à ce projet là dans l'état
actuel des choses annie oui ou non oui
oui honnêtement oui l'udc n'ont donc il
vaut mieux faire des tramways est
connecté sur les stations de métro qui
va voir passer encore 20 et en faire des
études pour savoir ce qu'on fait un
trait - comment va le faire quelle est
la stratégie puis dans 50 ans lui qu'on
va être en russie asie on a rien dit
c'est vrai c'est vrai que ça va prendre
du temps reconnaît les montréalais mais
par contre on va payer les rênes pendant
sont ok le deal avec la caisse a du sens
on sera plus lent simple actuelle